>> Tanuja is a
co-founder of DataGlen,
which is a early,
around startup, in
this space of solar energy.
Tanuja was
earlier a technical staff member
at IBM Research,
She finished a masters from MIT.
It's a pleasure to have
you, and she's also part of
the summer workshop
that we have here,
so she'll be around for
next couple of weeks.
>> Thanks Patrick.
Good morning, everyone.
It's great to present some of
the work that we're doing,
and I think it's very relevant to
Azure Analytics part that
we are talking as
part of the workshop.
So, as the name suggests,
I'm going to talk
about Bits and Joules.
So, some of the use
cases in energy
vertical and what
are the challenges?
How the paradigm is shifting?
How the modern day's technologies
or digital technologies
of IoT and
AI are relevant for
some of the problems
that you're trying to
solve in energy particle?
So, as all of us would
agree that energy is
a fundamental necessity
of modern society,
and as we have the access
to clean and cheap energy,
we can do a lot in terms
of the other sectors,
including the healthcare and
education and various
other factors.
So, it's important to
basically look at the
problem of energy,
which is the driving factor for
various other industries
and technologies,
in terms of the innovations.
Energy vertical right now is
going through a paradigm shift,
and we call that paradigm
shift as Democratization.
So, on the left-hand side,
you would see the
democratization of media.
So, few years back or let say 20,
30 years back, the media
was pretty centralized,
so there was content which was
created centralized way and
the content was basically
disseminated in
a distributed manner.
So, it's like
through national BBC
who's creating the content,
and the mass population
is basically just
absorbing the content.
But now in last 10 years,
there is with the social media
like Facebook and YouTube,
everyone can create the content
and everyone can consume
that content as well,
so it's completely changing from
the centralized to
decentralized manner,
very similar thing
which is happening
in the energy vertical right now,
which is democratization
of energy.
So, previously, there was
a central generation which was
happening at the form of
the hydro or thermal energy.
It was, the distribution
and transmission was
happening through
central entities.
Again, in India, most of
the utilities are doing
the transmission and
distribution right now,
and the consumers who are
basically the residential or
industrial consumers,
are just consuming
the energy without
participating in
the entire model,
but now we are shifting,
very similar to social media,
the change is happening in
the energy vertical as well.
So, there is distributed
solar and batteries which
is coming into picture,
there are electric vehicles which
are basically getting
commercialized right now.
So, it's completely changing
the way the energy was
generated and consumed.
So now, the commercial
or residential consumers
are able to generate
their own energy,
part of that they
might be consuming,
part of that they can basically
inject back into
the grid as well.
So, it's not
a one way flow but now
there is a two-way flow of
energy which is happening.
Obviously, the
traditional power plants
and traditional transmission
distribution network
is not designed to handle
this two-way type
of communication
or two-way type of energy flow,
and hence there are a lot of
interesting socioeconomical
and technical challenges
which are getting
created because of this.
So, we will go through some of
the issues in energy vertical and
how the computer systems
like IoT and AI,
can help solve some
of those issues.
So, the first issue
is of power shortage.
So, on the left-hand side,
this is the power consumption,
basically the power demand
from New York over the year.
So, basically, this axis shows,
over the year, how there are
variations in the power demand.
This particular axis shows
during a particular day,
how the demand is varying.
So, during a day, again,
there are one or
two peaks depending upon
the power consumption needs
and depending upon the season,
whether it's the summer
versus winter,
there's a variability
in the demand.
So now, if we look
at these plots,
these are again from
the New York City.
So, there was a highest
peak load demand here,
which was 2006 versus the 1980's.
If you see that, there
is no long tails
in this kind of distribution,
so these are basically
hourly loads in terms
of megawatt hours,
and as we are moving to
2006 and again to 2018,
we see very long tails of
demand which are there.
So, the demand is increasing,
there are short periods
of high demand,
and definitely to cater
to these kind of demands,
there is no point in adding
the infrastructure just for
catering to that
peak demand load,
so definitely there is
some other methods or
alternative methods are
required to curtail
toward address to
these kinds of demands,
which are coming on
all the networks.
The second problem is
of energy scarcity.
So, in general,
there is a problem
of access to clean
and cheap energy,
so this is something which we
have very much
experienced in India
where there are regular power
cuts or there are places
where there is no access
to energy as of now.
So, this figure is from 2018,
which shows that
across the world,
how much population is without
electricity right now.
As we speak right
now there is still
approximately 300
million people in
India who do not have
access to energy,
and that's because
of various reasons
of the cost which is required for
the transmission
and distribution of
the energy which is generated
at the central level,
as well as the other problem
of the availability
of energy itself.
So current energy generation
which is happening
through thermal
and coal power plants in India,
which is not sufficient to
increasing demand of
energy at various places.
The third issue that
we'll talk about is,
mainly the good part which is
happening is there is a lot of
renewable and alternate
energy sources
which are coming in
picture right now,
in the form of solar,
wind, as well as battery
storage et cetera.
Good parts out there
are quite in local,
so there are no transmission and
distribution losses
involved here.
They're are sustainable
and scalable.
So you can scale
these plans as required.
Most of these solar and,
solar especially, is
reaching grid parity,
which means that the
cost of generation
of energy from solar which is
becoming almost same
as cost of accessing
the energy from the thermal
or the existing
conventional plants.
But there are some disadvantages
in using these
renewable energy resources.
The first problem is
generation variability.
So, this plot shows
the generation
across the year from one,
single wind turbine.
So, as we see that there
is a huge variability
across the year as well
as during one given day,
there is a huge variability in
the generation which is
happening from
single wind turbine.
So, when we are
taking into account
the large adoption of
renewable energy resources,
if we are not able to
predict how much amount of
energy that will be
generated in next few hours,
then we cannot do
the unit commitment and
we cannot rely especially
on these kinds of sources.
So, it's very important
that how reliably we can
predict how much amount
of energy that would be
generated from these
renewable energy resources,
and it includes the
accurate weather prediction
and on top of that,
accurate prediction of
the energy from these sources.
The second problem is that
if you take into
account, let's say,
solar, then the solar
is available only during
few hours of day.
So, it's available
only from, let's say,
6.00 AM to 6.00 PM of the day,
and again there is a
variability in amount
of generation which is
happening from a solar plant.
So, we cannot rely on
this renewable energy
resources completely,
we need to have additional
systems in place to
backup whenever these
resources are not available,
and that's where basically
we are looking into,
storage technologies,
and how storage and other
technologies can be
integrated with renewables,
so that we can reliably
provide power supply
through these renewable
energy resources.
So, that's where now we're
going to talk about
the Participatory Grid.
So now, the consumer is
not just the endpoint,
consumer is not
the dumb or static consumer,
but consumer is participating
in the entire process
of energy generation and
consumption in various manners.
So, the four main points that
I'm going to talk about is
first is how we can address
the power shortage problem
by reducing the peak demand?
The second is how we can
address the energy scarcity?
On one side there
is energy scarcity,
which means that amount of
energy which is available,
that is not sufficient
to cater to most
of the energy resources,
but on the other hand
we see lot of
energy wastage which
happens in the residential,
commercial and industrial places.
So, can we identify
the energy wastage and
curtail those energy
wastage points?
The third one is how we can
basically maximize
the distributed generation,
or basically adoption of
distributed energy resources with
the additional resources like
solar and other technologies,
and the final one is looking at
optimal utilization of resources,
which means that
basically including
all the points of
preventive maintenance
and predictive analytics.
So, just going back
very quickly to
IoT technologies and why
IoT analytics is very suitable
to solve some of these problems.
So, we are looking at
basically the things which are
equipment setup at most of
these renewable or the
conventional energy resources.
Most of these are capable of
communicating data with
standard protocols.
So, we do not have to,
most of the cases,
we do not have to add
any new sensors as such,
the existing batteries inverters,
wind turbines or even
the smart meters which
are installed at
the home premises,
they are capable of sending
the data and the context
information as well.
There are some existing processes
in place which need to be
adopted to basically look
into the new technologies.
So, I like to basically look at
the IoT stack similar
to brain architecture.
So, as we look into the brain,
there are different
systems which are
responsible for different types
of actions which are
performed in our body.
So, if we look at
the Reptilian Brain,
it's basically governing
all the important or
survival instincts
of human body including
breathing, heart rate,
and balance, which are like
low-latency response events which
are required by the body.
So, those events
are basically being
handled very close to
the sensor systems.
The second type of brain
is Limbic System which
is looking at the feeling
and memory formation.
So, looking at more data
and generally forming
the patterns or memories through
that and the last one
is basically,
Neocortex which is doing
the reasoning forward planning
language and other things.
So, this is basically looking
at more holistically,
the data from multiple sensors
and making their
decisions on top of that.
So, can we look at
the IoT hierarchy of
systems in similar view.
So, we have sensors and actuators
at the level which are,
many times provided
by the equipment.
Then, they have
the data loggers or
edge devices which are sensing
and collecting that data
and capable of taking
certain actions.
So, the actions which
are required as
a low-latency response
actions or decisions which
are crucial to be taken in
the very near real time,
it's good to have
those decisions in
the system which are as
close to edge as possible.
Then, there are certain decisions
which require information
from multiple resources.
So, let's say, if we are
looking at the load across
the community and some
decisions that need to
be taken on top of that.
Obviously, we would
not be able to take
those decisions at
edge devices but it
might be in the Fog
or the Local Data
Center or the small
computing which is at,
let say, community level where we
can access that and
obviously, in the Cloud.
So, there was some initial
work we did while I was at
IBM on looking at
hierarchical decision system.
So, can we do the analytics
and the hierarchical manner,
where one node is doing
the computation which
is possible and
essential by
that particular node and
passing on information to
the next level of nodes?
So, depending upon the problem,
can we decide where
the analytics should reside for
that particular problem and can
there be a connection
between those nodes?
So, we have not
completed this work
after I left IBM research but
we are interested
in taking it up.
So, if there are any interest
in the similar kind of systems,
we'll be happy to
collaborate on this.
So obviously,
the Neocortex is doing
various types of analysis on
imaging time-series data.
So, getting back to
the Participatory Grid,
I'll start with the load
shifting problem which is
basically looking at
Peak Power Demand.
So, why reducing the
peak is important.
So as we see,
the X-axis is the time of day and
Y-axis is the power
production or their demand.
So, there are multiple peaks
during the day and
the power is submitted
as in the power is
generated by various different
types of load systems.
One is basically Baseload
which could be a hydrothermal.
So, which is a constant load
which we are getting
through out the day.
On top of that there is
an intermediate load,
which is again provided by
some conventional
energy resources
and then, there are Peak Loads,
which are typically provided by
diesel generators which
have low response times,
quickly can be started
and run through.
But if we look on
the right side plot,
it shows the amount of basically,
the price versus
the power generation
and the price does not
increase linearly.
As we go to the peak demand,
the price increases
exponentially.
So, if we can reduce
this particular demand
from a very small
tiny amount at least,
it significantly helps
in reducing the price in
this particular band when it
goes exponentially increasing.
So, there are historical
approaches which have been
taken into account previously
to shift these loads.
Some of these
approaches have been
Daylight Saving Time or
the Tokyo Brownouts and
CA Rolling Blackouts.
Also in India, we see that there
are these kind of
load shedding which
happens like a few hours a day
at different localities
to cater to the demand.
So, some part of the community
would be completely
shut down during
a particular point of time.
So, this is more like
a top-down approach where
the utility is deciding that I'm
not able to get it
to the peak demand.
So, I would shut down part of
the community and that would be
basically a ruling
load shaving that we
see often during
the summer times.
There are lot of other approaches
which are being tried out in
countries including US and Europe
with variable degree of success,
which are called Demand Response.
So basically, if you look
at the left-hand side,
it shows the typical
residential demand and what
part of the residential demand
is the deferrable or
time shiftable loads.
So, if we're looking at
electrical vehicle charging,
that could possibly be
a time shiftable load
or if we're looking
at water heater or
washing machines and dryers.
Those are time
shiftable loads because
it's not like you
need it immediately,
but it can be done over a period
of three hours of time.
So, there is a large proportion
of loads in the residential,
commercial and
industrial loads which
are kind of time shiftable
and can be taken
advantage of those loads to
shift from pick-time to
off pick-time so that
we can reduce the demand
and basically do the peak
shaving during those times.
So, when we started
looking into basically,
the problem of peak demand
and demand response for
India or the
developing countries.
The first challenges in
the way it's being tried
out in US and Europe is,
utility collects the data
from the smart meters or
individual appliances, let's say,
washing machine is
in-demand response,
then there is IoT device which is
sitting on the washing machine.
It's sending the data to
the Cloud and utility
sends the demand response
signal either for
the manual intervention or
automatic dispatching the
load to the some other times.
So, it requires basically
complete infrastructure
for communication,
centralize optimization
techniques where
you can send the signals to
the consumers and the consumers
would participate
in demand response.
There are few success stories
in certain utilities in
US who have successfully done
the demand response process
for shifting the load,
but we started looking at
the same problem for let's say,
India and Africa,
we do not even have
the sufficient infrastructure
for the network communication.
So, we cannot rely on
the network communications to
send the signal from the utility
to individual equipment.
Also, there are lot of equipments
which are already existing.
So, we cannot change
those equipments,
which means that there has
to be something which is
sitting outside of the appliance,
but still taking into account
the appliance preferences.
The third thing that we
wanted to look into is,
as to be as cheap as possible.
So, it has to reside on
a small device and
the third thing is,
the same appliance should be
applicable from
a range of appliances.
So, it should not be that
one type of appliance
is only running
for water heaters versus
washing machines.
So, it should be able to handle
multiple different types of
time shiftable appliances.
So, taking these multiple
things into account,
we built something nPlug.
Again, this is work which
I did while I was
at IBM Research.
So, what this nPlug does is,
it's like a smart socket
or it's like
over the power strip
that we generally use.
So, it sits between the wall
socket and their appliance.
The appliance goes
into the nPlug and
this nPlug is built using
a 16-bit micro-controller,
with very small,
it could be of RAM and
four MB of flash memory.
So, what it does is,
it basically does local
sensing and decision-making.
So, it senses the grid conditions
especially of voltage
and frequency,
to identify whether there
is a high load on
the grid or not.
It takes the preferences
from the consumer.
So, let me take an
example of water heater.
So, let's say most of
their time solar water heaters,
the water can be kept
heated because there is
insulation available for three to
four hours in the morning.
So, most of the times what
happens is we all get
up at six o'clock and
start the water heaters.
Water heater takes from
two kilowatt to
four kilowatt of energy.
Multiple such appliances come in
the activation and we
see the morning peak.
So, can we instead of starting,
everyone starting and manually
switching the
appliance at 6:00 AM,
can we switch the appliance
anytime between 3:00 to 6:00 AM,
because water can be any way kept
hot and ready for three hours.
So, the user can set
the preference that,
"I want the water to
be ready at 6:00 AM",
and it needs to be run
for 30 minutes let's say
for water to get heated.
So, then we can actually shift
this demand from 6:00 to 6:30 or
whatever time the user
gets up and six to
7:00 AM let's say it's
the peak demand time,
we can actually do it anytime
from 3:00 to 6:00 AM,
because that's the off-peak time,
there is no much high
load on the grid.
The user can set the preferences
that 30 minutes is what I
want to run the appliance
and 6:00 AM is
the time by which I want
the water to be ready.
Obviously, there are
"Override" buttons,
so some days you don't
want to set that schedule,
so you can always
override and say that I
want to switch it on at
whatever time I want.
So, without having
any external infrastructure
and just having the sensing
of voltage and frequency
inside the appliance itself,
we wanted to see how we can
identify the peak and
off-peak demand times.
So, the first part is
an autonomous operation or
decision making of identifying
when there is
high demand on the grid.
So, this plot shows the time
of day versus the voltage,
and each color is
a different day of the week.
So, this is the data
which was collected from
my house in [inaudible].
So, in the morning
you would see that
the when night the voltage
is high because these
off-peak times,
the voltage is about 230 isn't
nominal voltage we are expected
to have like 230 volts.
But typically, at
night we will see
it around 245 or 250 volts.
Whereas in the evening
peak times around six to nine,
you would see significant drop
which is like 220 volts.
This was in Bangalore where
this local transformer was
very close to my house.
We did similar experiments at
various different parts in India,
and we see huge variability.
So, if you go at some of the
rural places in [inaudible] ,
you have seen the voltage
dropping up to
180 volts or 175 volts.
So, we cannot just fix a
particular range because a range
varies across as you go
from one location
to other location.
So, we cannot just say
that anything above
235 is the off-peak
time and anything
below to 220 let say is
the peak time because
depending upon the location,
you have to adaptively
identify that what
is the peak and
off-peak time range.
So, we basically
collect the data at
every 30 seconds or
one minute time interval and put
the compression on top of it like
this is aggregate approximation,
for aggregating the signals
at every five minutes
time interval.
Then we look at basically
doing the clustering
of these particular time series
into three clusters of peak,
off-peak, and the median time.
Then we look at the patterns,
so let's say
the algorithm looks at
the last 10 days pattern
to identify what are the
peak and off-peak times.
So, based on that, it
decides that okay,
it identifies first of
all the thresholds,
which is the low threshold and
upper threshold for voltage.
Then identifies that based on
last 10 days pattern that this is
a time which is a peak time
and this is a time which
off-peak when they need
to take the control.
This wasn't previously
there were a lot of
techniques which
were looking into
the frequency data to identify
these gaps between
the supply and demand,
there was lot of work on this,
but no one has looked into
the voltage signals and buttons,
so that was one of
the contributions.
Doing these on
these small microcontrollers
in streaming manner,
is what we did.
The second thing is
looking at frequency.
So, frequency would be ideally it
should be 50 hertz and close to,
if we look at
the data from yours,
we would not see this
much of variability,
it's pretty close to let
say 60 Hertz over there,
but here we see
a huge variability from
let's say 49.2-50.2.
But still there are events when
it goes beyond
the normal threshold.
So, we identify what is
the normal behavior for
frequency and which other times
where there is imbalance.
So, if the demand is
high then generation,
then the frequency will drop.
So, we identify those events and
again capture for
shifting the load.
So, now we're able to identify
the off-peak and peak times
and we know that when we
should not be running
the appliance.
But let's say, now there
is no central controllers,
as such every device is going
to make the decision
independently.
So, we should not create
a problem of just
shifting the load
from one time to another time
by all of them
starting and shifting.
So, let's say all of them sense,
there are thousand influx and
all of them sense that it's
a off-peak time and
all of them shift to
another time and create
another peak demand.
>> So, what's the disadvantage
of what the [inaudible].
>> Basically, you are
ready to the peak demand.
So, if you are running
the water heater
and since utility is not
able to supply during
that time because
there is a cap on
how much energy utility can
supply at any given
point of time.
So, you would have
experience let's say
morning and evening
power cuts, right?
So, they typically do
the power cuts during peak time,
because they are
not able to cater
to the demand at that time.
So, that's like
a top-down approach,
they force everyone
to shut it off.
But what this one is trying
to do is like
a bottom-up approach
that the device itself
says that I need
not run only during
the peak time,
so I can shift my demand.
There are other loads rate,
let say there are lights and
air-conditioner and other things
which are not time shiftable.
So, we have to run those
appliances during peak time,
so giving chance to
the appliances which
definitely need to run during
that time and shifting the loads
which are kind of voluntarily,
rather than utility forcing
saying that
entire community would
go down from 6:00
through 7:00 AM.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> So basically, we then
discussed with the utilities
on how they can include as
part of the business model.
So, for industrial consumers,
there is time of
use pricing, right?
So, even in Karnataka,
there is a time of use
pricing where industries are
charged higher rate if they
are running it on pick-time.
So, we'll discuss
various business models if they
can give a rebate if someone
is running the load.
So, let say in
this particular devices
and able to send the audit log
at the end of the month,
which shows that it was not
running during the peak time.
Then, there could be
discounts and rebates,
as well as if there is
a time used pricing,
there is a straight use case for
the consumer to ship the
load during follow-up.
>> [inaudible].
>> So, that's part of
the user preferences.
So, there are certain loads which
are like a long-running loads.
So, if you take an
example of EV charging,
that would be running
over four hours
and you can basically
chop that four hours into
let's say six hours with-.
You can say that my window size
need to be 30 minutes,
so you should not be
switching too often.
So, if I give the chance
for a plants were
uninsured and for
at least minimum of 30 minutes,
so that's part of the
user preferences.
User can say, "Do I want
to run it at one go,
which is a case for let say,
washing machine that I
want to run it at one go?"
versus if it's the
inverters that we charge
at home or the
electrical vehicles or
even the water heaters,
where it can be chopped that
the entire usage can be chopped
at multiple time windows.
>> [inaudible].
>> No. So, the way
they had design it,
user has to provide
the preferences.
We wanted to keep minimal
inclusions in the device,
taking into account
the small size of that.
But that was a requirement
from a few discussions
that we had that if
the device is capable
of providing the usage
pattern let's say.
Let say, we can just collect
the data of all consumption
of an appliance,
can be categorize
what type of device it is?
So, can we categorize,
classify basically
the water heaters
from washing machines and
then automatically
put the preferences
of what category of device it is?
>> Is it different in
plant for each device?
>> It's the same model,
but if you are running it
for multiple
different appliances,
you would be putting
one for each.
>> [inaudible].
>> In this model, it was not.
But then there was
some conversation on,
let's say there are 10 templates
within one industry.
Can they talk to
each other and do
some even better optimization
in terms of distribution?
>> [inaudible]
>> Yeah. So, they did
these experiments on
the data collected from,
let's say, US houses as well.
As I said, the range was small.
So, even in case of
frequency and voltage,
the range is very tight,
but still, you would
see the pattern.
So, the pattern is available
over there tight range.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> Yes. So, you would see
a small variability still.
So, the variability
might be in, let's say,
then this two minus
two but still,
the variability is
available over there.
Basically, to control
this lot of utilities,
put additional devices for doing
multi-stablization and
frequency stabilization.
So, a lot of rather in India,
while the utilities, or
I think in few countries
in Europe as well,
the pricing in the
real-time energy market,
the amount of price that you get
paid for providing energy
at a particular point
of time is called ABT,
availability-based tariff,
that's dependent on
the frequency at that time.
So, if the frequency is low and
if you're supplying
energy at that time,
you get paid more versus
when if you are supplying
in this particular region.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yes. So, again,
it's not widely
available as of now.
It was initially done
as part of the pilots.
Now, as they're
putting smart meters,
the demand response
is generally done if
there is smart meters available.
But a smart meters giving
you timestamp data
already and being pushed to
the Cloud almost in real-time,
so that's where the analysis
is happening in the Cloud.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> So, I'll go to
the other problem where
we do look at the
power consumption of the plants.
But in this case, it was mainly
for identifying what is
the condition of the grid,
whether the grid is
overloaded or not.
So, if you look at the
power consumption part,
you will just get
to know that how
your appliances working
but you would not
get to know that your transformer
is overloaded right now,
and you need to basically
curtail your demand at
this particular point of time.
So, basically, once
the problem of
identifying the good
condition was solved,
then we wanted to look
at how we can basically
distribute spread
that demand over time.
So, we looked at
various decentralized
scheduling techniques.
We basically looked
at computer networks,
CSMA kind of protocols,
which tried to back off
when there is a high demand
on the network.
So, we call this algorithm as
a Grid Sense Multiple
Access similar to
Carrier Sense Multiple Access.
There are few
differences in this one.
So, if we look at this
similar computer
network algorithms,
there is no deadline for
completing the packet transport.
So, you can basically attempt
and send the packets,
whereas in this problem,
there is a deadline.
So, if I'm saying that I want
the water to be ready at 6:00 AM,
then 6:00 AM is my deadline.
I need to, no matter what,
we want to give preference to
the user's deadlines which
means that the water
has to be ready by
the deadline which is given.
So, we had to basically
do some modifications for
CSMA algorithms to suit to
the deadline-based algorithms.
So, the first thing that we
did was contention window,
depending upon
the available time slots.
So, let's say if I am at 3:00 AM
and I have a 30-minute slot.
So, I have three hours
which means
six slots which are available
or five minutes slots,
whatever number of slots
which are available,
the current time slot during that
particular 3:00-6:00 AM window
and how much time I
need to run that.
So, depending upon that,
every device basically tries
to identify
the contention window.
As the time elapses,
as you start going
towards their deadline,
your contention window size
starts becoming
smaller and smaller.
So, what the device does is,
let's say if I have seven as
the contention window size,
device chooses randomly
to sense at any
of these initial
seven-minute slots,
and identify sense the grid and
identifies whether it's
the loaded or not.
So, by doing this, we are
first of all
distributing the amount
of endplates with
just sensing and
making their decision
at the same time.
The second thing is
the probabilistic connection.
So, depending upon
the voltage levels,
so let's say the voltage
is below peak load,
then it says that you
should not be joining
because it's a peak time.
If it's above
the upper threshold,
which means that
it's a peak time and
device can definitely join
at any point of time.
If it's in-between,
then basically,
it computes
probabilistically that with
how much probability that you
should be joining the grid,
whether you should be starting.
So, by doing these
probabilistic arrangements,
not all endplates
would again join
at the same time
but they distribute
probabilistically and would not
increase the load beyond
a critical point.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> So, we did some experiments
on let's say if
there are two controllers,
two endplate controllers
in one house.
Obviously, if they can
communicate between each other,
there would be better chance
of optimization than this one.
If you are able to
do it centrally,
that would be a complete
optimal solution.
So, as we go up in the hierarchy
or from the H242 Cloud,
it might be giving you a bit.
Because you have higher
information available with you,
you would be able to do
better optimization.
By taking into account
the constraints of,
we didn't want to write any
communication infrastructure,
not even the connection with
Wi-Fi or the other points.
So, because of that, we
decided that we would make
their decisions
locally and we would
see how much the
difference it comes to.
If there are not many sensor,
if there are not
hundreds or thousands of
sensors being controlled
at one location,
this one still gives the same
performance as if it's two,
10, or 100 still gives
the same performance.
>> For households, this
is still okay to that?
>> Well, even households
and industries which have
less than 100 or 200 devices,
this still works equally as if
you had taken
the centralized decision.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> So, that's another as in I
can point you to the paper.
Where looking at users load.
We tried to identify
what are the preferences
of running their devices and
based on the context of how they
would like to run
their devices over weekends
versus let's say weekdays
and other things.
So, these are the results of,
we tried it in simulation and
some controlled experiments
in real world.
So, basically here it's
creating two peaks
during the day.
There are different
types of inputs
like water pumps and
washing machines,
water heaters and inverters,
which have variable preferences
in terms of their time window,
how much they want to run?
The starting times and
durations and other things.
So, we are considering
let say close to I think
400 or 4,000 of such appliances.
Even when they are taking
these independent decision
in a decentralized manner,
because now they can shift
this particular peak
spent three hours or
four hours before
the actual time duration.
It's able to actually
significantly spread
the demand over time.
>> is this simulation or
is it actual measurement?
>> This was in simulation.
So, we did various simulation and
then we tried it in
the control experiments
of 100 devices.
So, 100 devices we ran on
multiple different appliances and
users said there are
preferences as their need.
So, we didn't have control over
how they said the preferences.
So, now we're moving
from the load
shifting to energy
efficiency problem.
So, there is one thing is
there is high demand
which utility
is not able to get into,
but on the other side,
we see that there is
lot of wastage of
electricity which happens.
The wastage could be because
of the aging appliances like
Aging refrigerators or
the cooling systems.
In US itself
30 to 45 percentage of
each HVAC system had to
operate at below
efficiency levels.
So, this could be again
because of two reasons;
one is that the malfunctioning
or aging of their
appliance or inefficient
use of appliance.
So, it could be that
the air conditioner is running
by individuals and
doors are open.
Which means that it's not
running at the optimum levels.
To address this problem,
what we did was
something similar where
it's called as a SocketWatch.
Which again sits between
the appliance and
the wall socket,
and now it looks at instead
of looking at the grid,
it looks at the power consumption
of that particular appliance.
So, we collect data of
active or reactive power and
various other parameters
which can be sensed
from outside of their plants.
Then we try to model
the benchmark model for
that particular plant.
So, here is an example
of washing machine which
goes through different modes
depending upon
the settings that you
choose on the the
washing machine.
It has different signatures
of active or reactive power.
So, we identified these
states of their plants,
whatever appliances running
in during the benchmark time.
So, this is a learning phase
when we collect
the data and build
a benchmark model.
So, here it's basically
showing that there are
different states of
power consumption of
their plants and how
the states are transitioned from
one state to another
as a Macro model.
So, with the probabilities
of going from one state to
another state depending
upon various factors.
So, there are two phases,
one is the learning phase
when we identify the modes,
depending upon the active or
reactive power consumption.
The states depending upon
the time spent in
each of the mode.
So, sometimes the same
power consumption
but if it's running
for different time
intervals means
differently or it's
a different state.
Then we look at the periodicity
between those modes.
So, for example if we are
taking example of refrigerator,
the defrost heating might
be running once every day.
So, that's the
periodicity of that.
Or, if we see the cycling
of compressor,
it might be running at
specific time intervals,
which is a periodicity and
then the state transition.
So, how the device
transitions from one state
to another state.
In the model, once you
have the benchmark model,
in the monitoring phase
we do two things;
one is the standby
mode correction.
So, if we identify that
the appliances is
running on standby,
then it's switched off and if
we identify that there is
a change from
the benchmark states,
then we basically alert as
a malfunction or inefficient
use of the appliance.
So, every appliance while
it consumes the power,
it consumes the power
in two forms.
So, one is the,
so basically the breakage
of your power consumption.
Which is termed as it has
a phase angle and it basically
gives you two parameters.
That how much is
active or reactive power,
depending upon if your load is
inductive or was capacitive.
The amount of active or
reactive power would change.
So, the combination of
active or reactive power would
define in some sense what kind of
operation is happening
in your plants.
>> [inaudible]
>> So, basically if you
measure any appliance's
power consumption,
you get these two factors of
active or reactive power.
So, it's just sitting outside
and measuring power consumption,
that's all it's doing.
So, there is a lag between,
as in it's power factor between
the active or reactive power
which is a phase angle of those.
So, here are some of
the examples of
identifying the issues.
So, this particular one
of the refrigerators,
as in this is the
benchmark model.
When you see that
there is typically,
there are states like
compressor cycling,
compressor going on and off.
Which if you look
into the clusters,
it basically identifies
different clusters
which are states in terms
of power consumption.
There is a periodicity,
so how much amount it stays in
the compressor on mode
versus compressor off mode.
This refrigerator after building
benchmark model,
we identified it.
We basically changing
the states and
then they look back and found
out that there was
a gasket leakage.
So, what's happening is,
since there is a gasket leakage,
it's not cooling sufficiently.
So, it's not able to
take its cooling,
so it was not identified by
the user because it seems to be
working fine but it
wasn't ever going into
the compressor off mode,
because thermostat is not able
to activate the
compressor off mode.
So, if you see here,
it's always on and
there are no cycles of on
and off kind of a thing.
If we look into
the clustering or the states,
here was the
compressor off state,
which was coming periodically,
which was completely missing
from the actual
operational model.
So, just moving next
to the distributed
generation part.
So, basically, these
are called Microgrids,
so the examples which I
talked about earlier.
Because they are
doing the generation
and consumption at
the same location,
so they are called Microgrids.
There are various forms of
Microgrids like Offline,
which are completely
working independently,
or there are Backup or Online,
which are typically
the solar storage
in the house where you are
getting grid power
as well as you have
your own system of the grid.
It has been historically,
we can say,
the consumption and generation
happening at the same place,
so they're historically
different Microgrids,
but obviously, those
are not efficient.
So, the problem that
we discussed earlier,
previously, the user were
just doing consumption.
So, it was simple on
and off of a switch.
Whereas now, when the consumer
is called the Prosumer,
where there is a local
generation and consumption,
the complexity of the problem is
increasing on the consumer side.
So, this is like a time of
use pricing which is
provided by the utility.
So, depending upon
whether it's a summer
or whether it's a weekday
versus weekend,
there are different prices
for per unit prices.
You have the solar generation,
which is like we don't
have much control over it.
This generation is happening
depending upon your weather,
you can just predict
degeneration how much
it can be there.
You have a battery. So
the control that you have
is how much battery that you
can charge and discharge.
Again, the problem at
the small scale is
being handled at multiple
different stages as well.
So, there are something which is
called as Virtual power plants,
where you have
multiple different types
of power generation equipment.
It could be wind, solar, diesel
generators, solar batteries.
So, how can you activate?
So, basically, virtually,
they create a power plant,
and let's say if you have
the requirement that
this Virtual power
plant need to be
supplying a particular amount
of demand during time,
how can you choose
the right set of
generation at right time so that
the overall cost of
generation is minimized?
So, starting from
the individual household level
to the large-scale generation,
the same problem is being
tackled at multiple
different levels.
>> [inaudible].
>> So, in earlier two problems,
we're still running with
the conventional sources
but tackling to
the power shortage
and electricity wastage.
Here, it's mainly we are taking
into account other
non-conventional integration,
and that's happening at
multiple different levels.
So, you can choose any subside or
of power generators
which are available.
Each of them would have
different pricing for
per unit generation,
and they have different
availability times
and different constraints.
So, taking all these
constraints into account,
how can you fulfill
your demand in
real time while minimizing
the total cost of generation?
So, that's happening
at individual
household industry level
or the utility level.
The interesting part here is you
need to make the decisions of
which generations to switch
on or off in real time.
So, this requires
very much computations
which are as close to
the generators as possible.
So, if you are let's
say collecting
data from wind turbines
and solar together,
obviously, you need to
collect both data and make
the decisions on the cloud.
But let's say if you're doing
these decisions for the house,
then it's good to
make the decision at
individual house
level rather than
collecting data at the cloud
and making the decision
because of the latency
and network issues.
>> [inaudible] what's
the cost of each liters
that you need documents of it?
>> So, basically, it's called
levelized cost of energy,
which takes into account
additional costs of
maintenance and all other things
over the time of whatever period.
So, now, if let say
we are taking into
account batteries
levelized cost of energy,
you need to take into account
how much battery life is.
So, whatever garbages
that you are putting in,
you would be expensing it
over four year's time.
Depending upon how many
charge and discharge
cycles you make,
the battery life is
going to go down.
So, that is another constraint on
when you decide how much to
charge and discharge
the batteries,
that how many
charging-discharging cycles
that you are taking into account.
Each of these resources
have similar kinds
of constraints.
So, there are some times
when wind turbine if
the wind is too low,
it would still
generate energy but it
would run very sub-optimally
during those times.
So, your levelized cost of
energy during those
times would be
higher so it might
be better of to run
some other generator rather
than running it on low.
So, here, basically
the problem is
our forecasting generation
from each of these assets.
So, generally, now even
utilities in India have started
posing every plant which
is more than five
megawatt capacity.
They need to provide one day in
advance that how much generation
would be happening from the plant
at every 15 minutes time slot.
Then there would be
revisions during their day.
Similarly for small houses,
if you are running it for
the individual small house
or a commercial entity,
we need to know
how much generation is
expected from the sources
in real time,
a day in advance
so that you can do
the optimization and
if there are changes,
you need to be able to
adjust to those changes.
The second is similar to
the generation forecasting,
you need to do
the load forecasting.
So, how much demand
is coming from
your residential or
commercial place
and how would you be able
to cater to that demand.
Next is optimization problem to
comply with the policy. So, yeah.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> So, it depends upon how
dividing is done inside house,
but that's something
which is possible.
So, because of cost
constraints on something,
generally, some people do that,
let's say solar
power is supplied to
only few appliances and
grid is supplied to
all the houses kind of a thing,
but the combination and
mix is possible depending
upon the wiring that
you do of your house.
Again, depending upon three-phase
versus one-phase loads and
other things there
are few constraints.
>> [inaudible]
depend on the time of device?
>> Yes. So, there are
two types of that.
So, there is one is
the consumption tariff where
the consumer is charged depending
upon how much amount of
energy user is consuming
at specific time of day.
Then there is other type of
tariff which is called
feed-in tariff,
so depending upon
how much amount of
energy you are injecting
into the grid.
Sometimes it's constant
throughout the day,
sometimes there is
a time of use as well.
So, this is the other problem
where depending upon the pricing
and the policies which
take into account
the additional constraints of
let say levelized
cost of charging,
discharging batteries,
and battery life,
the optimization needs
to be done on the grid.
So, this is a problem which
we are working on right now.
So, right now, we do
the head forecasting
and push the results
to the box or Edge.
Then they do small
optimizational,
simple optimization if
there are any changes.
So, we are basically working on
how we can do the revisions
on the box itself,
because if there is
network disconnectivity
or other issues and how we can
basically provide
the optimization
and mode of this matter
on the Edge.
So, there are
penalties associated
if your generation is not correct
beyond 15 percent for each
of the 15 minutes point.
So, these are the policies
in India right now,
and we need to be able
to cater to those.
So, another problem which is
not on the Edge but which we
are trying right now is this is
the Microsoft Research Building.
So, if we want to have
larger adoption of
renewable energy resources,
we need to be able to
identify the user,
need to be able to identify how
much is the potential of solar on
my particular roof and
how much amount of energy
that can be generated.
So, basically, this identifies
the area of the roof and
classification of the roof.
So, depending upon the dates,
the south-north roof or it's
the east-west roof
or it's a flat roof,
the capacity of solar
that you can put
on in then and its all
our potential word body.
So, we are doing some work on
the image optimization on there,
and there is already
some open source work on
that core loop and solar map
if somebody is interested.
That was mainly for
the French datasets.
We are looking at
Indian datasets for this.
Finally, the
efficient operations.
So, this is mainly about
the predictive maintenance
and root-cause.
So, since we collect data from
various appliances in solar,
there are different types of
failures which are possible
across various sensors,
including weather
sensors, inverters,
MPPTs, and other things.
So, we tried to identify
proactively and
reactively those faults
and alert the users.
This is the cycle for data
collected from
the IoT platform right now,
and this is how the Real-Time
Portfolio View looks like.
So, there is something
that we are doing
like online offline module,
where the central user wants
to look at the entire data.
So, if I'm the independent
power producer
who has 25 plants across India,
I would want to see
in real time how
it's performing over
my entire set of plants.
But many are times
this large plants
are at remote locations.
So, there are always
problems of network connectivity
and other things.
So, if the entire model is
sitting only on the cloud,
the site engineers who
are siting at the ground,
they are not able to access
this system as well.
So, we have something
like offline sync model,
where it's a subset
of functionalities
available on the fog
at the plant itself,
and opportunistically, it swings
with the cloud datacenters.
Then identifying
various under-performing assets.
So, we have shared some data
with [inaudible] team as well,
so we would like to explore
some of the techniques
that they have used here.
So, this is the
cleaning schedules.
So, cleaning is one of
the important issues in solar,
which drives the inefficiencies.
So, without adding
any additional sensors,
just like looking at
the power consumption traits,
we are able to identify when is
the cleaning required and how
much is assaulting losses.
Again, this one we were doing on
the cloud right now and
we're trying to push
it in the Edge as part of
the workshop experiment
that we're doing.
The last one is combining
time-series and image data.
So, one is we are getting
this time-series data of
power consumption and
other things from
individual equipments.
But we're also trying
to get some data from
either tomographic imaging
or the normal cameras,
so how we can
combine these two to
identify the right fault
and decide what type
of dust it is or what type
of soiling it is and
activate the auto cleaning
mechanism appropriately.
So, there are a lot of
interesting, other startups,
and other corporates
which are working on
energy problems using
AI and IoT technologies
across the world.
We'll be happy if there
are any problems which are
of your interest and we'll be
happy to collaborate
with you. Thank you.